hello folks
welcome to rational science
and uh we divide our lecture
in three parts first part we usually do
extension
then we do physics today we have
transparency
what the hell is transparency
and uh then i open the floor
up for questions uh comments that people
have made since last time we're going to
try to address those
okay so let's get started uh this past
thursday i had a little
pow wow a little debate uh interview
with
ed ed dutton
and as usually happens in these cases
you know there's a little bit of
interview there's a little bit of debate
uh not everybody sees
eye to eye on all issues so we don't
have the same
foundations on which we build our
theories
and that creates a little bit of a
problem because
uh you know the interviewer is supposed
to
question you and that's okay but then if
there
are many questions we all go on tangents
and we
end up doing a lot of tangents we get
lost on the big picture
you know we don't really know um
everything that had to go on
you don't answer all the questions that
you were supposed to
or address all the issues and that's
just the nature of the beast
you probably would need 15 hours
to cover every point on which you know
to make sure that
each point is covered in every basis
is is a set so that everybody can follow
the whole
presentation okay so uh
mr ed dutton uh he this
differed with me in at least three
issues there were more that
we did not see eye-to-eye on i'm sure
but these were three that i kind of
pulled out of the
conversation that i had with them very
interesting
first one uh where we do not see either
ion
is that he said that survivors will
reproduce and restart population
expansion
assuming there's a global economic
collapse with
collapse which is what i'm proposing
the question is will there be some
survivors
and my guess i guess his guess as well
is if that happens you know the global
economic collapse happens there will be
some survivors
and the question is whether they will
reproduce and restart the race
that's the question and this comes from
uh i think
in a lot of these anarcho-capitalists
uh i call them narco caps
and they um they have this idea that
it's a good deal
if the world collapses the world economy
collapses
and you say what you want the world
economy to collapse
they would say yes a lot of them would
because they think it's a
reshuffling of
global economics we raise the board and
start all over again
with the fact that you know we know
history we know what happened
in the past uh we get rid of all the
lousy politicians
maybe the military you know and you do
your own thing
you know entrepreneurship where you
uh you know just trade with your
neighbor and you have no
taxes no government on top of you this
is the notion a lot of these people have
and so they see it as a good thing you
know let the global economy collapse
once and for all and let's restart the
whole thing over
and so that's where some of these
questions
or disagreements start
and so survivors will reproduce and
restart population expansion
and i'm saying no uh when the global
economy collapses
that's it for mankind there will be no
restarting of anything
and so these are some of the points that
i want to address
uh regarding that issue okay let's start
with that one first
uh family survives see you got to look
at this in every city
what's going to happen in a city okay
and a million people they'll all kill
each other
or leave the city and look for food in
the country
whatever there won't be many survivors
in the city whoever's there
whoever ends up being king of the
mountain has to be maybe a family
someone who trusts
uh someone else and maybe you're talking
about 10
15 people at most i would think you know
and that family for some reason survived
managed to
tough it out beat out all competitors
and you have to beat out every single
one because you're going to be planting
and you don't want to leave anyone out
there
you know stealing or or from your
agriculture or destroying your crops to
create problems for you
no you have to kill them only one
there's only it can only be one king of
the mountain there's only one
family or group that survives and so
that's the first issue you gotta
look at okay it's not like we're gonna
be friendly with
with our neighbors or anything like that
everybody's going to be an enemy of
everybody else everybody will understand
that immediately
okay now all of humanity has collapsed
as far as you're concerned you're the
last humans on earth this group
right and so you're going to already
have a big psychological
impact in in that group you know you're
going to look at the world and say
we're it we're the last humans on earth
so there's also
already going to be a psychological
impact there
okay think of that situation think of it
as if you were the last group of people
living in a city
there's no one miles around okay
and you're gonna do subsistence
agriculture that means you're not going
to be a no man because you're not going
to be doing hunting
there will be nothing to hunt
you don't see wildebeest running down
the highway today do you
so there's nothing to hunt okay all the
hunting has been done we've killed all
the humans
as far as you're concerned so you're
going to be planting
if you survive and if you plant you're
going to be sedentary
there's going to be no one near you by
you and near you
okay so um you're gonna have no
electricity no water no internet you
know none of that
okay so uh keep all these things in mind
uh you're gonna go into subsistence
farming hopefully
you've are a farmer or you have some
farming experience and you're not an
office
uh person you know you're not an
internet uh
entrepreneur because you probably know
nothing about planning
okay so that's another thing you got to
keep in mind
uh and so these people say uh this group
is going to reproduce and restart the
race
the human race again well i don't know i
have a lot of problems with that because
you know
first of all women don't produce today
don't reproduce today
much less will they reproduce after the
collapse
when they're the last humans on earth
this little party that's there
that survived the whole uh holocaust
holocaust
and so the the issue is you know they
don't have
children today when they have doctors
they have hospitals they have all the
care that they want and now they're
gonna
have to have children in the streets
more or less you know
no one to help them it's just push the
baby out hopefully everything's okay you
know no cesarean or anything like that
so i don't know i don't know if a woman
will want to
be put herself in that situation
as well you know i mean the old days
they did it but the women today
they're not prepared for that kind of
stuff okay out in the
caves i don't think so um
then let's assume someone reproduces you
know that group
will have no genetic diversity no no i
mean it's it's probably a family
uh people who know each other are very
closely related
and we already have humanity
doesn't have any genetic diversity let
alone a group within
humanity so let's assume they reproduce
what's going to happen 2-3 generations
later well they're going to start
growing six figures that's what's going
to happen
you know come out wrong because they
came out of the this founders effect
this group
that founded the new colony so
it can't go on for many generations when
it will collapse
that group will collapse so that's
another reason they probably would not
have any children they would just live
out their lives
that's it and
lost the birthing habit you know women
don't have children today why would they
have
children later on when you know what's
the purpose of having a child just to
see what it looks like
just to make that chat what woman will
want to have the last
child on earth as far as she's concerned
that is the last child on earth
and will she have two or three what so
that they can intermarry
in breed i doubt it
you know so think about these things and
then uh yeah brother
will marry uh sister essentially
because it's the same group is that
what's gonna happen
with uh all genetic diversity
essentially gone
i don't think it's gonna last too long
and yeah they think of this as not the
end of but as the beginning
and uh i doubt very much that's how
you're supposed to look at this
now when it when when the global economy
collapses
that's it for mankind okay so uh
i i don't think uh they'll be
reproducing or doing anything along
those lines
okay next issue more or less along the
same lines because he questioned you
know
uh how about all these tribes out there
you know uh lost tribes
that are not in contact with uh
civilization
and a lot of people have raised these
issues in the past with me you know they
say well what about the lost tribes
they're not in contact with us
and so i think they've got the wrong
reasoning here
first of all there are no lost drives we
found them all
okay we know we've got satellites for
those of you who are not flat earthers
we can see a match box from the sky
here on the ground okay and so they know
where everybody is on planet earth
now there are groups out there which
have no relation to humans
uh i said to civilized humans but what
happens those uh
those hunter gatherers you know
they'll be the first to go i'm saying
that we will kill them
first uh why because you know if you
look at a city
that is close by to these jungles or
where these
people live they'll be invading
their hunting grounds first to get
something to eat and then they'll be
hunting the
less technologically advanced tribes
they'll kill them all so i that's
i think it's the other way around the
first people to go will be the lost
tribes
okay the amish people see the amish
they're they're great people you know
they do farming
they're very skilled yeah that's why
they're gonna die they're the first to
go why because
they don't pay a a they don't pay for
a security they don't have a defense
budget they take that one for for
granted
right now their defense budget consists
of you know the courts
police the army maybe they're protected
and who's going to protect them once all
that's gone
no everybody's just going to invade
their lands and just steal whatever they
they want out of there you know it's
going to be like the locusts
swarming over the land that's what it's
going to be like so lost tribes
amish all those will be the first to go
they have no protection whatsoever from
what's protecting them now in fact the
indian government the uh
group that i talked about about a couple
weeks ago the sentinelese
sentinel island it's the indian
government's gotta protect them
because otherwise other people would go
in and do all kinds of things here
which are you know again they have more
knowledge they have
helicopters they have guns they would
slaughter these people very easily
so the indian government protects them
they
they all these lost tribes are under
protection right now they will not have
that protection later on
okay uh but the one concerns me the most
uh
is the last one that i'm sure we didn't
see eye to eye on
and that's that humans have more genetic
diversity today than in the 19th century
that's how dutton looks at this and
i think he conceded that we lost
genetic diversity since uh
the human race started so if you go back
200 300 000 years ago
and your work your way upwards to where
we are today
we lost genetic diversity over the
centuries over the millennia
and if that's the case then how is it
that we
recovered or we increased our genetic
diversity since the 19th century
and of course we didn't see eye to eye
on that one and i can do a smile what
can i say you know
if you don't agree don't agree right and
i'm saying you cannot recover
genetic diversity okay this is a
little graph that i made it's in my book
okay and the neanderthal book there and
gives you an idea of why
we can only lose gender any species for
that matter can only lose genetic
diversity
it can never gain genetic diversity
human population versus genetic
diversity and
that's over time okay and i'm saying
that mutations increase
genetic diversity but periodic
population crashes
in other words diseases wars etc natural
selection
chops off genetic diversity big chunks
of human
of humanity die in wars and disease
and whatever little you know you you
gained
you lost in these big choppings and so
it's like this saw
sawtooth wave you know it's a big
crashes
and you have what is known as a
founder's effect followed by another
crash a population
bottleneck of some kind and then another
crash and so on down the line
and so all you're doing is streamlining
the genetic diversity of humans
from the moment that they began to
inbreed
okay so we've been in breeding what 200
300 000 years
we should have very little genetic
diversity in us
and this is hard for these people to
believe because you know the geneticists
have told them something else you know
that we gain
um genetic diversity
uh because of mutations and it's like
okay so we gain and what do we lose
and i'm saying we lost a lot more
through founders effect
and population bottlenecks and this is
what these people
still have not caught on to i don't
think there's a
single geneticist on planet earth which
will agree with me
that we have only lost and we can only
lose any species
can only lose genetic diversity over
time
okay and if you add
to the founders effect in the
population crash the uh bottleneck
okay if you had the fact that there's uh
also inbreeding for this for all this
time
that can only worsen the situation you
know
and i'll just give you these examples
here you've got a
fellow named charles ii he was of the
habsburg family okay and
uh king of spain and he was known as
el ecisado the bewitched okay
and why because well he he was born with
all kinds of problems
and you know he had the famous habsburg
chin
which he inherited at least as far back
as his great great great grandfather
five generations back which was charles
the first uh
known as charles v of the holy roman
empire charles the first of
spain okay and they had this this
habsburg
chin and it's because they kept
intermarrying in inbreeding within the
family
and we had the same situation with the
romanovs and you have alex a
uh romanov he uh he was
uh um grandson of queen victoria
and there were nine people within the
uh victorian family that had hemophilia
and he was one of them and so and it's
because
of inbreeding you have the same thing
with the amish the amish
have been inbreeding for 300 years
they came to america like 500 of them
i have the dates there 1717 to 1750
and in 300 years they multiplied to 330
000 that
approximately that they are today and
for the most part all these people just
been
inbreeding and income from that stock
so so what do you think they have today
well they have a lot of genetic problems
what genetic problems
okay ailments or disorders
whatever you want to call them and we've
been inbreeding for what two hundred
three hundred thousand years
assuming those skulls you know the omo
and the adult and so on
are part of our lineage which is
probably
likely because their skulls are very
similar to ours
okay so assuming those are our ancestors
you know our
predecessors we've been in breeding for
200 000 years
and what do you think is going to come
out out of there especially with all
these bottlenecks
and founders effect bottlenecks founders
effect
well what you're doing is whittling our
genetic
uh pool and today we're all clones of
each other i mentioned the other day and
i mentioned this several times because
people don't seem to pick up on that
there's a study and here's a study
that says that you know a pack of champs
a troupe of chimps
maybe 100 of them that live together and
have sex
within the group have more genetic
diversity than
all the human race all the human race
eight billion of us
and it was surprising to the uh people
who investigated this and they said
how can that possibly be if if here we
are
so many of us eight billion people why
would a pack of chimps
you know uh have more diversity than us
and and of course the geneticists have
no clue why that's the case and i'm
telling you the case
is that
all you can do throughout history from
the moment you beg
begin inbreeding is lose genetic
diversity
due to again founder's effect in
bottlenecks
and also inbreeding and so here
you know we have a pack of gems that
have more diversity in all of the human
race
and it's like people don't understand
what this means this this is very
important
it's very important because it shows
that genetic diversity
is a function of time so you want to
know
if a species is old or new
find out how much diversity it has if it
has a lot of diversity
it's a new species it started a few
thousand years ago
perhaps if it's got very little genetic
diversity
such as you know the sheep it's because
they have a long line in which they've
been inbreeding
for who knows maybe a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand years
and and today they've lost uh their
genetic diversity so
i'm saying that uh if you go back in
time you can figure out
you know uh how old a species is just by
looking at
how much genetic diversity it has and
again mother nature doesn't look
at uh uh
a species age right
only through how many times the earth
went around the sun
okay looks at how much
inbreeding there was and how many
diseases
you went through and how quickly your
your population expanded
so there are other factors that you got
to consider there all that taken
together
and again i talked about that in my book
on
the neanderthal book uh in more detail
okay uh so here's uh my take on that
and i'm not asking people to agree with
me or to believe in this i'm just saying
this is my take on this okay you take it
for what it
is worth to you i'm saying this is the
law of genetic diversity
okay a species once it branches off from
the mother trunk
it begins to gain genetic diversity
because it meets
different environments different
diseases different animals and so it
uh conditions its genetics to that new
world in which it's
going through and in the case of
neanderthals you know they came
out of certainly out of the heidelbergs
or the antecessors which
came before them who in turn came from
from
homo erectus okay so uh if you have a
homo erectus who
uh a pack or a family or a clan whatever
going west and they started to live in
arctic weathers and then from that group
uh
what branched out were the heidelbergers
okay and then from that group another
group branched out and they became the
neanderthals all in europe
arctic europe well up to that point they
were increasing
their genetic diversity from one species
to the next
but what happens after that once they
settle down they become more or less
sedentary they don't
you know move to warm climates or
whatever
then after that all they can do is lose
genetic diversity
okay and eventually uh they end up at
a point where they get used to
endemic diseases the diseases which
would
have killed their uh forefathers no
longer killed them
and the reason for that is that you know
all the
people who had no defenses are already
gone
and either there you know they didn't
leave any offspring
so disease is a big
sifter of genetics of the genetic pool
and streamlines our genetic pool so
after
millions of years thousands of years
hundreds thousands of years millions of
years
you end up with a species that has no
genetic diversity
and one of the big animals today the
cheetahs
have very very little genetic diversity
i think it's the number one with the
least amount of
diversity out there and this gives you
an idea that cheetah has been around for
quite a while
inbreeding grew fast very successful
animal the more successful it is the
shorter
its lifespan we were very successful so
we only lived 200 000 years dinosaurs
were
horribly successful and so they lived 2
million years
much more than we did and so you got to
keep all these things in mind mother
nature handles these things
not again how many times the earth goes
around the sun you got to factor some
some other issues there and today you
know here's an example of
uh animals that have lost their genetic
diversity they're known as the lions
and here's a weird thing that you'll
find among them this is a female
lion ness and she's got a mane like a
lion
okay i think that's another one there
i'm not sure if it's the same
one but the point is we're starting to
see creepy things
in the world of lions why because they
lost their genetic diversity
uh you know i keep saying that there
were like 150 000
lions only 30 40 years ago and there's
only
35 000 today so the pool
the population has shrunk and within
that
obviously the genetic diversity has had
to
shrink you're not going to get more and
more diversity with fewer and fewer
population especially when
there's been such drastic cuts in their
population
so keep all this in mind so yeah we
don't agree on a lot of things
and so it's very hard to
get to the bottom of uh the theory
unless you see eye to eye at least in
some of these things or they're
clarified
that's one issue the other one i always
recommend is that um
you know we do extinction 101 before we
do
extinction 102. okay
okay let's look at some of the issues
that some people raised
regarding extinction and in neanderthals
and so on
one fellow says there was a case of a
wolf boy in cuba
talking about the appearance here okay
that got the attention and love of quite
a lot of girls and i assume women when
he grew up
okay i guess he's talking about little
red riding hood seeing um
grandma what big teeth you have you know
okay and he says essentially uh
you know there are women go after eight
men you know men that look like apes etc
okay
and men going after anything that moves
okay we have these
notions out there these hollywood-esque
uh 21st century notions
and uh you make a big error when you
compare that
to what happened in the paleolithic
totally different
context people are just mixing things up
they think that
you know since humans today you know you
see videos here of uh
men who go behind a cow you know and do
their thing
i don't think that happened in the
paleolithic
okay but today you know
we have all these weird things we have
triple x and people are over sexed and
so on so
they have all this leisure time to think
about sex and so they
they think of weird things and i'm not
sure
sex was that complicated in the days of
the paleolithic i think it was just
you know i've got the the uh
feel and you go to your
squad and you say okay get down
i think it was more simple in those days
sex today we have a very complicated
world we're
bombarded by sex every morning you know
and so
yeah you can think of anything you want
but anyways he was getting to the
following he says
uh so theoretically it's conceivable
that humans might
be open to getting it on with
neanderthals if these were peaceful
animals
and here he said to a certain degree a
mouthful because
one of the issues is you know you'll see
many
uh some movies out there or some bids
where
they show a guy you know sneaking up on
a donkey or a horse or on a
cow they see humans will sleep with
anything
they get this notion um
i want to see a human sleep with a lion
okay a lioness right or a female who
allows to be um you know
mounted by a lion out there in the wild
how about an alligator is that
a good match there humans with
alligators
you know so so when we're talking about
apex predators and that's what
neanderthal was neanderthal was an apex
predator you have to consider him like a
lion like a
alligator like a shark this guy was a
top guy there he
he he went out he he went out for the
kill
and you're saying that we just barge
into his territory knock on
his uh cave door and say hey uh do you
have some sugar
and while you're at it uh do you mind if
i sleep with your wife and
i'll let you sleep with mine you know is
that the way it happened
it was all friendly like and let me hunt
in your hunting grounds let me catch
some stuff here
yeah sure uh again people don't
understand the situation here
and so yeah i have a problem with uh
humans sleeping with uh
neanderthals and here let me show you a
little story
okay it's a love story so you'll
probably like this okay here's a love
story
love story of two apex predators okay
apex
animals one is known as the lion the
other one's known as a tiger
and now they're in different habitats
but it turns out that the tiger decides
to migrate
and he goes i don't know to the
serengeti okay planes there
and he goes into lion territory okay
now the first thing you gotta think
about is that you know the worst enemy
of a lion is another lion
they kill each other or the pride for
whatever the it's got
they got it in their genes and the worst
enemy of a tiger is a tiger
okay turns out this tiger goes it now
into
not a tiger territory he goes into lion
territory
okay okay he goes in there and uh he
runs into lion territory separated by
time and habitat remember these two
animals
uh they have a common ancestor maybe two
three million years ago
and now you know they're going to meet
each other
you think there's going to be love at
first sight
or or are they going to try to kill each
other which
which would you bet on out there in the
wild
okay and they have different culture you
know the um
a lion is a uh social animal the
tiger is a solitary animal i think i
have a picture here that yeah
see uh lions live in packs in uh prides
they call them ryan they have kids and
so on
the tiger he's a solitary animal he's
got several females out there
each one also individual lives
individually and he goes and visits each
one
okay but the tiger and the tight grist
are lonely
animals they're they don't live in packs
they don't live in clans
okay so keep that in mind as well okay
okay um they have little genetic
compatibility because they
do have ligers and
tie guns and they look more or less like
this
okay you can see that there's a little
bit of a mixture there
but of course these animals that you see
there these sari animals are grown in
zoos
and they have the tiger mate with the uh
lioness and the lion mate with the
tigress
okay things humans do
and a lot of these animals are infertile
you know they come out even though
they're born sometimes you know
they they don't they don't reproduce
some of them do apparently
you know but they have to mate i think
with one of the
purebreds okay so that's not clear in
all these cases
but anyway and anyways how do you think
that's going to last uh
these you have these ligers and thai
tigons you think they're going to meet
with another
one like them and have more kids and
more kids and more kids forever
or is there something wrong eventually
with these mixtures
okay so keep that in mind ask yourself
that question
uh okay so the turns out
they don't fight the tiger and the lion
they meet out there in the serengeti and
they decide to make love instead of war
okay and again uh they end up with
ligers and tigers
and so but now we're gonna try to
explain the disappearance of the tigers
it turns out the tigers
became extinct and so now you come
you know 50 50 000 years later
and you try to explain that you say okay
the tigers came out of
india they made it with the lions in the
middle of the serengeti they have two
different cultures
they were separated genetically for
hundreds of thousands of years
okay but they get together they have
ligers and tigons which
apparently were for infertile okay
but we'll even concede that they were
fertile okay just for the sake of
argument
in order for you to explain why the
tigers finally became extinct you would
have to have
every single tiger mate
with the um with the lions because
otherwise if you have two tigers
that it they would have continued
having tigers and the tigers would still
be around
if the tigers became extinct it's
because even to the last one that
reproduced had to mate with a lion
it can't just be a one-night stand and
this lion and this tiger over there it's
gotta be the
entire population eventually for all
tigers to disappear
otherwise they will continue having
tigers and the tigers should
still be around okay so what i'm saying
is uh that's what happened to uh the
neanderthals
if if the neanderthals um
would have made it with us uh
then every last one of them had to
eventually
mate with humans in order for their
smaller population as they say maybe 10
of our population to be diluted
into our population and eventually all
neanderthals disappeared and again one
of the issues there is what is a species
were they the same species or were the
neanderthals a different
race because that's another issue
that dutton had in his mind he talks
about race and i say race is a political
word political issue it has nothing to
do with science
in science we talk about species that's
objective either you can have children
or you can't
viable children and if you can't
then you're two different species and so
you know this uh
notion that these people have that they
call introgression
which is nonsense idiocy it's idiocy
because it
violates the definition of the word
species they say
introgression means that two different
species mate and they have a child
back again and that's they use that as
you know try to explain why you know uh
some
um and some like humans have
uh neanderthal dna because there was
introgression
or the denis venisovans and any of those
uh hominids and so they're saying
uh essentially there's been
introgression meaning
two species different species because
again what is a species
that can have viable children if they
can't they're two different species
they're saying these two different
species had a viable children
a viable child or whatever and they're
contradicting the definition
of species and again all these people
never define their terms
properly scientifically so they they
get out through loopholes that's the
problem with
by not defining their terms so no the
word integration should be
deleted uh or we have to clarify the
difference
between integration and species those
two words are contradictory
okay you can't use them both one has to
go out
the door okay uh so what happened to the
neanderthals well
again we have a little bit of problem
because humans have known neanderthal
mothers
okay we have no empty dna no
mitochondrial dna
from no human has any mitochondrial dna
from neanderthals
mitochondrial dna is passed down by the
mother
to the her children and we have none
among
humans today and so they have to explain
this and this comes out of the wikipedia
and it references
uh several papers i put two of them
there and says due to the absence of
neanderthal-derived
mitochondrial dna which is passed on
from mother to child
in modern populations it has been
suggested that the
uh progeny of uh neanderthal females
who mated with modern human males were
either rare absent or sterile
that is to say admixture stems from the
progeny of neanderthal males with modern
human
females so the way they explain this
today
is that uh you know we we
we men we were smart you know we were
smart we
we had good eyesight and we saw that
monkey there we said i'm not gonna sleep
with that monkey
but the women you know are women you
know they're just whatever
uh maybe they sold their bodies for you
know
i guess a handful of seashells
you know and so the neanderthal came
over and said hey cutie you want to
sleep with me tonight
i'll give you all this all these
seashells these rocks
and she did it that's what they're
saying we have no mothers but
apparently we have fathers it turns out
we don't have fathers either
because uh they could find no y
chromosomes from
neanderthals which are passed from
father to sun so it says due to lack of
neanderthal derived
y chromosomes in modern humans which is
passed on from father to son
it has also been suggested that the
hybrids that contributed
ancestry to modern populations were
predominantly
females or the neanderthal y chromosome
was not compatible with
homo sapiens and became extinct
okay and again those are the references
there there's a couple more you can look
this
up so um let's see if i got this right
um humans don't have
neanderthal mothers because we have no
mitochondrial dna okay great it was we
only have fathers
turns out we have no men today have no
neanderthal fathers
because we have no y chromosomes from
neanderthals
and still in spite of these obvious
pieces of evidence which they got out of
the genome and so on
they keep saying oh but we interbred you
know our
forefathers interbred with neanderthals
and they tried to explain it away
instead of taking the easy
way you know uh uh
john oak uh uh donna bocom's room
um take the easier path
they don't do that they say uh no we
have to prove
interbreeding at all costs against all
odds and we had no neanderthal mothers
we had no nano with old fathers but we
interbred with them
yeah sure uh i think uh it's easier to
suggest that we never had anything to do
with the neanderthals okay
in bed and so yeah again it depends on
what assumptions you make and
uh all this comes from the geneticists
and i explained that
a couple of weeks ago where the
geneticists
uh have taken over the neanderthal
paleontology business
and they call all the shots today so the
guy who's out there in the middle of the
field
collects a bone you know paleontologist
um
indiana jones kind of style uh type of
guy
he goes out to the middle of the
mountains
you know dust some bones off brings them
to the museum
you know assembles them
and he says well why did these guys uh
disappear what happened to them
and so they come up with all these
theories well it was the climate change
maybe it was um
you know we killed them we went into
their territories and started killing
them
maybe we out-competed them maybe they
couldn't stand again the cold or who
knows
what happened and uh geneticists came
over and says
oh you guys are wrong you know nothing
let me tell you how they disappeared
they disappeared because they
interbred with us and here's the proof
two percent
commonality in our dna
and then they discover there's no
mitochondrial dna
we have no y chromosomes but we still
intermarry because they have no
other theory for extinction of the
neanderthals
and again the question is were the
neanderthals of different species
could we have viable children
fertile children or were our children
sterile because we were so far
separated not so much in time which is
also an important factor maybe
five hundred six thousand seven hundred
thousand years ago we we had a common
ancestor
but on top of that the neanderthals went
to the arctic
uh europe and we were allegedly in
africa unless you got a better
mousetrap and you got a better theory
fine but i'm saying right now
those are my assumptions i'm saying
humans cro-magnons right
our forefathers they came out of africa
they went into europe
they couldn't get into europe because
they were killed by the neanderthals as
long as the neanderthals were there the
clans
once the neanderthals were gone we were
able to get into europe
and that was approximately 40 000 years
ago
when we conquered the land conquered
europe and
as we advanced the neanderthals were re
seeding because they were dying
they were dying what because their
population pyramid
overturned the nandhul neanderthals
disappeared
in a population implosion
it happened within their own world
and we couldn't have interbred because
there's another
argument there as well which is how did
the
heidelberg you know homo heidelbergensis
how did he disappear
did he make with neanderthal is is that
how he disappeared
how did homo erectus or homo antecessor
how did he disappear
did he mate with uh homo hydo bergensis
is that how species disappear they mate
with the next one down and they
get uh diluted into a bigger population
again it shows that geneticists have a
mental problem
okay that's the way i look at that they
know see
geneticists is not a scientist he's
has nothing to do with science a
geneticist is a person who just counts
atoms he doesn't even do it like you
know with
beads on an abacus he's got a computer
that reads all these billions of
base pairs and so on and spits out the
numbers and he can compare them that's
it
so he looks at that and said okay this
this one coincides here this one doesn't
go inside there
and so far all he is is a stamp
collector that's all he is up to that
point
it's when he gives you an explanation a
physical interpretation of what happened
that's when he crosses the line into
science that's where
he gives you the most irrational
explanation he can come up with
interbreeding in this case and and
and at that point you stop them you say
you're not a scientist a scientist only
gives a rational explanation
and what these people have to do is not
tell me how what percentage
of our genes are or dna
come from neanderthals what they have to
explain is how did these two species
do it in the wild and have a fertile
offspring
that's what they have to explain if they
cannot explain that
whatever they come up with is garbage
absolute garbage so they don't tell me
uh that we have two percent dna i don't
care about that
i want you to tell me how they did in
the wild how a lion mates with a
tiger in the wild that's what you were
gonna explain if you can't explain that
you know because that's never happened
for sure you know or
even animals that other animals you can
pick the animal you want it's never
happened in the wild
okay because there's no need for a um
a chimp to visit the gorilla
territory and have sex with a gorilla
and again you know there was no need for
neanderthals to have sex with humans
didn't they have females in in the
national world
were they so sick of them they wanted
divorce they want to marry a human
are you kidding me or what you know so
that's what you got to explain
anyone who talks about inbree
interbreeding
or admixture between neanderthals and
humans
don't tell me what percentage
neanderthal dna we have tell me how they
did it in the wild
these two apex predators how they
you know uh became neighbors and lovers
that's what you gotta explain okay
another fellow will raise this
an issue says there's an italian author
who hired an artist to draw
his own design of a neanderthal yeah i
don't think he's
italian i think he's australian and uh
ben graham mini
bendra mini and um you know i i looked
at his stuff
a long time ago i don't subscribe to
almost anything he says except the fact
that um
you know that uh neanderthals were very
different than us that's true
but you know he uh he also believes in
that
we made it with them so so he he says we
were so different that it's almost
unbelievable but we had children
together so
you know again nothing different now the
father raises the issue of pilt down man
he said prove the frailty of uh
fossil reconstruction yeah we have this
guy charles dawson i think i talked
about him in the past
and he uh played a hoax on the
uh anthropology slash paleontology world
he filed some teeth and so on so he
created these
skeletons and he said oh i have a new
species just to get his name in lights
then he died he died shortly after
he made all these discoveries and he had
discoveries for many years by the way
not one just many there's uh like 70 or
80
um you know frauds that he committed
and they went back and studied a lot of
these and they found out he was a total
fraud
i don't know on the one hand it's good
because you know it
compels the paleontologists to be on
their toes
like you know you can't just say
anything you want then later on discover
that it wasn't like that then you look
like a fool so
now if anything just served uh to
put the neandertha the uh
paleontologists on their toes they have
to be careful
that someone doesn't put something out
there that
embarrasses them uh phil says
uh regarding the definition of life
which again is the opposite of death
which is extinction right
concerning your definition of alive okay
it's a object that moves against uh
path of least resistance okay
specifically gravity okay but yeah
uh considered a molecule for molecule
doesn't literally everything take the
path of least resistance
and all i can recommend is you go to the
river and swim against the current
you'll be able to swim against the
current if it's if it's not a strong
current you know
uh rock can't do that okay so uh just
test it out for yourself okay
swim against the current you'll find out
that you can swim against the path
of least resistance something that a
rock cannot do
okay again we should do
extinction 101 before 102. that's one of
the things that
we did not do with dutton we should have
done something like that
and there's a reason for that okay and
i'm saying that first before you can
understand human extinction you gotta
understand what a mass
extinction is and what has happened no
one has defined these terms
you know like look at background
extinction what is a background
extinction
well you look it up look up the term
background extension
you'll find it in the wikipedia and they
talk about the background extinction
right it's a rate it's a mathematical
thingy
and we don't know what a ma background
extinction is they talk about the right
no so i had to define these terms
because no one else did
and what is a background extinction
background extinction is the
disappearance of
one species okay
that's what a background extinction is
don't tell me what the rate is
tell me the cause why does one species
suddenly disappear
from the record you know neanderthal
disappeared all by themselves
and you would think that woolly would
have disappeared before neanderthals
because neanderthals hunted bullies
with the woolly mammoth right it turns
out that will he
outlive them by 20 000 years
he's how can that possibly be if um
if neanderthals hunted bullies well
maybe that's not how
species disappear you know by over
hunting maybe there's something else
going on
and that would you know turn your lights
on that something is not quite right
in this notion that people have that we
for example over hunted the neanderthals
killed them no no maybe the nano
disappeared for something
totally different than has nothing to do
with over hunting or
over predation or whatever you want to
call it okay
so yeah willie also disappeared all by
himself
no no one got rid of him people say well
yeah we killed them
that's all they can think of we killed
in the end of the we killed the willies
we killed the passenger
pigeon we killed the great awk we killed
the um
what is it the uh tigers this uh the
tasmanian tiger we kill them all
yeah sure we're such mean people the
dodo bird you know we kill them all
so uh yeah so the question that i have
put in the past is why do animals on
land disappear more or less at the same
time as the animals
in the seas because if we can figure
that out
that issue then maybe we get a handle on
what causes extinction why
what underlies a mass extinction okay
and for that i
start with the definition what is a mass
extinction
and so we define the term and the term
is
the disappearance of a food
chain mass extinction disappearance of a
food chain now i wonder why they
disappear maybe it's got something to do
with food
what do you think okay
and so uh yeah you gotta answer the
question why the
animals on land disappear approximately
at the same time as animals in the seas
and one guy gave it a shot and he said
um
is the answer to your homework question
about the sun or ground
nutrients earth's surface nutritionally
reaches critical
mass approximately globally and needs to
reboot
thus land and sea dies and there i
have this chart which i made and that's
uh that
no that doesn't happen see when the and
i'll just give an example there
when the uh ferns were dying out
the conifers were already expanding so
it's not like the land dried up
and then you know god invented the new
plants again
invented conifers no it was there
there's a uh
there's a period in which both plants
are on the planet
one is disappearing the other one is
expanding and what happened to the
conifers is the same thing conifers
expanded for
what almost 200 million years between
the jurassic and the cretaceous
and what happens they're expanding but
at some point they start declining and
what's
occupying the land you know are the uh
angiosperms
and so uh there it's not like uh
you know there's a uh total wiping out
of
one plant and then the other one can
starts out or continues or whatever
now one is already um
alive and expanding radiating at the
same time the other one is declining
and that's that's the history of life on
earth we find conifers together with
ferns all the way to you know the
beginning of the
permian okay another fellow
uh says that maybe it's the oxygen
cycle you know it says primary producers
emit gases mainly o2
due to photosynthesis whereas consumers
produce co2 in turn
which is absorbed by primary producers
which are more numerous
and again this is the oxygen cycle
another fellow has essentially the same
explanations he says i remember having
read as a teenager
that the first great mass extinction was
caused by o2 emitting
microorganisms which was toxic for all
anaerobic
organisms including themselves okay
newer organisms on the other hand were
able to adapt and thrived
on oxygen creating a new ecological
pyramid
maybe a similar phenomenon occurs in
cycles
yeah i don't believe it's got to do with
a carbon cycle nitrogen cycle or
oxygen cycle the question of why uh
animals on land disappear more or less
at the same time as animals
you know in the seas uh but a guy hit it
pretty much on the nose and i think i
owe him a beer then and
this is uh what he said he said uh
extension 101
primary food producers in sea and land
spawned only a few million years apart
okay
hence their evolutionary lifespan is
similar
and hence rate of loss of genetic
diversity
including population pyramid overturned
of the plants
it's and phytoplankton
uh maybe even the um
uh other plankton as well uh the
zooplankton
uh you know they disappear more or less
at the same time because they started
out more or less at the same time
is it because god ordained that no it's
just because that's the history of life
on earth you know
there was a mass extinction more or less
at the same time
on land as in the seas and then what
started the radiation that starts after
that on land and in the seas more or
less starts at the same time
so they have more or less the same um
amount of time to live until then
that collapses as well and so we're
we're talking about
big um orders of plants
okay and it takes millions of years for
them to live and finally die their
population pyramid overturns
and so yeah this fella hit it pretty
much on the nose and
i owe you a beer guy whenever we meet i
owe you a beer
okay take a rain check
okay um
here's the evolution of plants that
supports that more or less
you can see that again this is the chart
that i make uh
regarding the big picture of what
happened
of on life on earth and you can see that
essentially you know you can see the
different ages you had the permian and
triassic that's the age of synapsids
mammal-like reptiles those were the age
of ferns especially seed ferns
you know you have the glossopterous
end in the middle of the permian i'm
sorry at the end of the permian
and you have what the dichroidiums that
disappeared at the end of the triassic
and so when those plants disappear it
turns out yeah the animals disappeared
together with them
and where the gymnosperms uh did they
begin were they born at that moment in
time now the gymnosterons the conifers
date all the way i think even to the
carboniferous they found some but for
sure
to the permian uh how about the
angiosperms the flowering plants
well they date to at least the middle of
the cretaceous that's when they expanded
but you could take them all the way to
jurassic
so these plants lived together
side by side and the dinosaurs did not
eat
the angiosperms because they were born
with conifers there's no need for them
to switch
plants at the last moment you know when
the angiosperms are expanding at the
expense
of conifers okay especially cycads and
cycadioids and so on okay
um final issue fella says
uh so my understanding
of extinction was referring to the
dutton
talk the other day that the cessation of
technology to feed
x billion causes a mass exodus that
loots edibles beyond replenishment
resulting in chain
extinction of human food sources
i don't think it's got to do with
technology
it's got to do with the fact that no one
produces
the food because right now we produce as
much as we want
but the only reason we produce food is
because of money
because of profits and the agricultural
corporations as long as there are
profits they'll produce and distribute
to the cities
but once money is no more which is my
argument
there's no need for for these
corporations to produce or distribute
and so the only issue we have to address
then after that
is why will money disappear why will
we refuse to accept money
that's the issue okay so that's and
that's the one people
want to get their brains are around you
know why would money disappear
but what i can guarantee to you is that
if money disappears right for whatever
reason god comes in and weighs
this magic wand i don't care if money
disappears if we no longer accept
money okay agricultural corporations
will not produce
food or distribute them to the cities
without food
you are guaranteed to die you a mass
extinction
can be guaranteed if you remove the food
from the planet okay so what the problem
is right now we produce a food
we produce our own food we take it for
granted because you go to the store you
say i got all the food i want
yeah now because someone is putting it
on the shelf for you
someone's doing the hunting for you okay
and they put a
you know with a golden spoon in your
mouth and the question is
if money is gone if there are no more
profits no more bitcoin no more
fiat coin no more gold we don't accept
any of that stuff anymore paper
plastic gold gold rocks because
gold is just a rock diamonds we don't
accept
any kind of money because food is the
only
thing of value and the only thing you're
going to accept is food and no one
trades food
in the jungle then if
no one produces or distributes food
you're guaranteed to die and you have a
mechanism of a mass extinction right
there
okay what is a mass extinction the
disappearance of a
food chain okay we got that
okay let's get on with the
main subject of today which is
transparency and physics what is
transparency
well this week we did a little
experiment three experiments really with
my son
one of the experiments just uh
verification kind of thing
okay and some people say oh bill you're
doing experiments
don't hold it against me uh in science
we don't do experiments
in science we explain experiments
you can do all the experiments you want
but if you don't understand what you're
doing or you haven't learned anything
from doing your experiments
you're not a scientist you're not a
physicist you're a physicist
a scientist if you can explain how that
happened
then you're a scientist but if you do an
experiment you say
okay here's an experiment i'll let go of
the pen you know they go the pen and
falls to the floor to
my desk in this case okay so i do it you
got to do a repeatable for it to be
scientific right okay let's do it two
times at least okay
so we have a a uh repeatable experiment
we dropped the pen two times you want me
to do it a thousand times it would take
a little too long
a million times the pen falls to the
floor
to the center of the earth great so we
did the experiment
you want to calculate how fast all that
stuff go
go do it i don't care that's description
that's like saying uh i'm going to
scribe a chair
you know it's got four legs a seat back
rust and
uh two armorers great great math
and what have you explained and so if i
let go of the pen and it drops to the
center of the earth and i do it a
million times okay i learned that the
pen falls to the floor
i described it i can do it
mathematically and say how fast it goes
what the acceleration is 9.8 meters per
second square whatever
what have you explained we still don't
know why what causes that pen to fall to
the floor
and so doing experiments is not science
science is explaining we're going to try
to explain transparency today
so we did a couple of experiments with
my son here's one of them
and uh what we do we put a laser
through air then we do it through glass
okay and then we pour some water in
there okay
and you can see that water goes through
i'm sorry laser goes through water as
well
okay one more time just in case
it goes through air through glass and
through water through all three of them
okay uh the laser here's through
air you can see it goes right through
the air doesn't stop that laser
okay go through glass you can see
nothing's changed there
and when we pour water in there it goes
through water as well so it goes through
water
through air and through glass and all
three of them at the same time
okay so uh we proved it okay we proved
it
uh air water and glass are transparent
proof please give me my noble okay
okay but we didn't stop there we did
another experiment okay and
this was something similar and what we
did here we did it with a pencil
and here are the three possibilities
here's the first one
first through air okay
then we put it in glass and you can see
there's very little change it's almost
perfectly transparent
but when you put water in there it kind
of starts breaking the pencil
it breaks the pencil in too okay so you
can see how the
pencil got broken over there okay okay
so we have uh
proven again that uh these are
transparent
okay um you can see right through the
water
and through the glass through the air
you can see the pencil
the only thing that the water you can
say is uh
kind of distorts the image a little bit
and here was the third one also along
that same line
okay and we put two uh
glasses one with water and the other one
without water
and you can see what happens with the
one with water as we
take it up and down it distorts the
image of the pencil
whereas the glass doesn't okay you see
what's happening there
you you go up and down with the one with
glass only
and it's uh almost the same image
whereas when you go with the one that's
got a little bit of water in it
there was a curved uh glass
you can see that it distorts the pencil
and why is that
uh a problem or why is that significant
well because um
here you see some of the values for air
water and glass and you can see the
molecules per
cubic centimeter for oxygen you find
10 to the 19 molecules okay
whereas for water and sio2 glass right
you find 10 to the 22 molecules they're
more or less
uh in the same boat there's a little
difference there but they're they've got
the
same exponent whereas uh air doesn't
okay and therefore comparison you see
co2
uh carbon dioxide okay also in the 22
range
okay so we have these three they're in
the 22 range
but look at the refractive index and you
see air which is close to vacuum on one
okay triple zero and a three there
water much higher one point three one
and one third
and sio2 it's got a range of 1.4 to 155
industry a semiconductor industry we use
1.45
but what is strange about that is that
you saw the distortion
from water when uh when we put the
pencil inside the water and so on
and it turns out that the refractive
index of sio2 is
much is significant noticeably higher
than water
and yet the sio2 is a perfect
transparency
whereas water is not okay so that's my
point there
point that i'm trying to make there okay
um
so let's look at this let's see what's
going on okay here's a
a little gift there here we have this
glass of water we have water in the
center there at the bottom we have glass
i
put that crystal structure of
sio2 and it's fixed it doesn't move too
much at least it does move a little bit
because it's a somewhat fluid glass is
water moves a lot more and i would say
air moves even a lot more
air is less dense than the other two the
other two have more or less as you saw a
minute ago
almost the same density okay okay what
happens when we
uh run
light through this uh this three
uh system in other words through air
through water and through
glass well here it is okay if you uh
shine light through it well you'll find
that it goes right through all
three of them which is what we showed
just now with the laser the laser goes
right through all three of them
okay but we have a little bit of a
problem here because
see what you see there are waves but
what is a wave
okay so let's find out what this wave is
let's look at it in a little more detail
and a wave is something that looks like
this
it's a bunch of vectors that's what it
is
what is a vector well it's got magnitude
and direction it's a mathematical
concept there's no physical object
called
wave wave is a verb
okay and you can see the arrows there
those are the vectors
and they're moving up and down and
they're also moving sideways it's it's a
very scary stuff you know very strange
thing you have these vectors
numbers that are moving up and down they
also move sideways concepts mathematical
concepts that move
very scary stuff so there is no such
thing as a wave
anyone using a wave is not doing physics
he's doing math
okay the uh
theorist has to tell the crowd
what it is that is waving and there's a
whole bunch of people out there say well
nothing is waving we
never figured out what it is that's
waving well then we will not allow you
to use the microphone
you're not allowed to give your talk you
you have a lot of work to do to figure
out what it is that's waving you should
go back to your dark basement
you raise your board and begin
brainstorming again you gotta
you gotta identify what it
is that it is that is waving until then
you can't use the word wave and say a
wave is what went through water wave is
what went through
oxygen a wave is what went through
silicon dioxide
you can't do that because there is no
such thing as a wave
wave is forbidden in the word in the
world of physics
okay so what did the people do usually
in quantum mechanics well they replace
the wave with particles
so now we're going to run particles
through them and say see the particles
go through air go through water and go
through glass
okay no problem i mean we can live with
that
what's the problem the problem at least
from our
current uh understanding or the way
quantum mechanics presents this
to the world is that um this is their
atom
this is their atom and that's their uh
photon that's their energy
whatever energy is a concept also a
mathematical concept
and that blue ball that's going around
that's the electron and the green
little squiggly arrows that are coming
out of there that's light
and it's known as energy also energy
light whatever you want to call it
and that's not a physical object either
it turns out that the
little ball that's going around not only
is a point particle meaning there's no
physical object there called an electron
because it has no size
that's the official version but we have
another problem even if it did have
size and it was a ball why doesn't it
fall to the nucleus
what prevents it from flying out of the
atom uh spontaneously
so until you can answer those questions
you don't even have a hypothesis for
what this
photon is or what an electron is we have
problems with both
okay so you can't use the particle of
quantum mechanics
you could use it if the electron and the
photon
are corpuscles you know like in
classical mechanics
they used to think in terms of
corpuscles little grains of dust
balls whatever you want to call those it
was
a something it had diameter it had size
that's not what the quantum mechanics
mechanicers
are talking about what they're talking
about is something that has no
size no volume zero dimensional
okay no radius no diameter we're talking
about a nothing
why because they're not they're talking
about a function they're talking about
a um an equation that's what it is a
number
so you can't use the quantum particle
quotations on that word particle you you
can't use that because it's not a
particle
it's not a physical object for the
purposes of physics
you cannot you're not allowed to give a
physical interpretation
with that concept okay because a
particle is not an object it's
an absolute concept it's a mathematical
concept more specifically it's an
equation a function
okay so you can't use those but if
you're going to simulate with corpuscles
okay then these are the variables that
you have to consider
when you're looking at transparency at
what goes through
air water glass okay and here you see uh
the different variables that you might
encounter that you have to consider
this is more or less a brainstorm here
okay
uh for interaction the corpuscle either
strikes an atom
uh travels through the atomic diameter
remember
um rutherford said
rutherford said an atom is mostly empty
space
and that's what people repeat today as
dummies because they don't know any
better
because if it's mostly empty space again
you gotta explain why the electron
doesn't fly away
okay what's holding the electron to the
proton assuming the electron was a ball
a little dust particle or you know has
size and so they can't explain either
so they don't have a physical
interpretation but they say okay
assuming it is a corpuscle uh it goes
through
the center of the atom it goes through
anywhere within the
volume of the atom or it can go
between atoms so those are the three
possibilities as far as interaction
either it collides okay with the atom
it goes through the atom meaning really
the proton in the center
like brother ford did he sent atoms
directly at that center and they bounced
back right so it either collides
bounces back okay ricochets uh
reflects goes through
or goes through in between two atoms the
space between two atoms
those are the possible interactions of
uh photon with
matter okay density a few molecules per
centimeter cube
many molecules per centimeter cubed is
transparency an
issue of uh how many
molecules how much substance a thing has
okay that's another issue you got to
consider another variable possibility
how about motion well uh of the
substance right
well it could be a solid a liquid you
know fluid or
gaseous and yeah those are a function of
temperature but the deal is
you know is is transparency an issue of
how solid something is
okay that's another variable you
have there another factor frequency well
uh we can't really use frequency if
you're going to use the wave unless you
identify
what the wave is what it is that's
waving you got to identify that
but assuming you can identify that well
then you have three possibilities either
it's within the visible range okay
uh or outside a visible range either
it's uh
below um
infrared or above ultraviolet okay so
so those are the possibilities there
okay and so um how do these people
answer these questions which ones are
they going to use to
explain transparency here's uh
how stuff works and they
chose really that density one you know
whether there's few molecules or many
molecules
how stuff works says air is a gas
compared to a solid air contains very
few atoms and
is very light think about a balloon
filled with air compared to a balloon
filled with sand
the air balloon is incredibly light
compared to the sand balloon
okay that's because there are many more
atoms in sand than in
air so they're going to do this on a
basis of how much
matter there is in there okay because
air contains so few atoms light waves
run into very few a
few of them and when they shine through
air
so the air looks transparent if you put
enough dust in here the particles of
dust absorb the light and the air stops
being transparent
okay so how stuff works says well this
is an
issue of um of how much matter you've
got there
i guess how many walls of atoms and a
lot of people have this
notion also that it's a question how
much
how many uh atoms are are width-wise you
know
how much how many atoms the uh
beam of light has to go through okay
another fellow says no this is totally
wrong
which gives me an idea that they still
don't have it settled okay
i mean if how stuff works which is a
pretty prominent site
on the internet gives a wrong answer
that means the mechanics don't have any
idea how this thing
really works they're all kind of you
know giving ideas brainstorming ideas
and as well says quantity of atoms have
no bearing on transparency if the
chemical bonds in a substance
have the right energy to absorb in the
visible spectrum
you can see through it if they absorbing
the infrared and ultraviolet
instead such as glass light travels
through
and so again they're talking about this
frequency wave that you see there at the
bottom
visible range above visible range or
below the visible range
okay this is what this file is
suggesting
okay and this is more or less the party
line today
because um uh and
by the way this file does um give an
example
and he does it with iodine and he says
look if you have a glass
okay out there a beaker
you can see right through the beaker
okay
but if you put iodine in iodine gas
which is lighter than glass in other
words it's
less dense than gas you suddenly you
can't see through there you know it
you can see it becomes more and more
opaque
and the question is you know then it's
not an issue of how many atoms you have
in there because there you see it
um the gas has
is less dense than glass and yet uh
glass you can see through and through
this you can't which is more or less
what i said about you know the
what you saw earlier about the
refractive index through
glass versus refractive index through
water okay okay um
let me get rid of this
get rid of this too
okay uh so the party line is essentially
uh
that it says that um
the uh light is knocking on an electron
and remember a little electron ball has
no
size and yet this photon which also has
no size
is going to hit this no size electron
and it's going to
hit it so that it knocks it into a
different energy level
and so you wonder how this how a photon
man you know it's got it's got very good
uh
aim it's gonna hit this non-existent
electron and move it into a higher
energy level
does that make any sense to you you know
zero dimensional photon hitting a zero
dimensional
electron and even if it did hit
i mean how many photons are you gonna
need to hit
one of these electrons i mean how many
electrons does hydrogen have
uh like one
[Laughter]
okay so hopefully you throw a shower of
a photons to hit that electron and
you know boost it to a higher or lower
energy level right
okay so uh this is more or less the uh
i can get it up here in a second here
this is the uh version of uh
establishment
materials are transparent to those
wavelengths of light
again wavelength what is that i don't
know i don't know what a wave is
for which there is no mechanism within
the material to
absorb those wavelengths okay glass
electrons require much more energy
before they can skip from one energy
band to another and back again
okay so again we're saying uh the
photons
have such good aim they hit this
non-existent electron the zero
dimensional electron and boost it to
a different energy level that's the
explanation
consequently photons of visible light
travel through glass instead of being
absorbed or reflected
okay and they continue okay here's
the other version of the complementary
part to this okay
says glass silicon dioxide absorbs light
in the infrared and the ultraviolet
wavelength ranges
infrared radiation can stimulate
mechanical vibrations in the molecular
bonds
of the material hence is absorbed
ultraviolet radiation is energetic
enough remember high frequency right
to free some electrons from the
molecular bonds thus
is absorbed okay in the range between
infrared and ultraviolet radiation in
other words the visible range
neither atomic vibrations nor electron
transitions are stimulated
so those wavelengths are transmitted and
the material
is transparent these are their
explanations today
okay what's the problem again the
problem we have
is that they don't use
objects they don't use things they use
mathematical concepts they're
redefining these concepts turning them
into physical objects they talk about
electrons when
electron is a zero dimensional nothing
and they talk about photons which is
another zero dimensional
nothing they talk about energy bands
which is a mathematical concept
we have no physical object in front of
us yet they're trying to give you a
physical
interpretation for transparency they're
trying to explain to you why
light by
oxygen and other air water and glass are
transparent
okay so i mean if they're going to later
on say that that's just philosophy
okay then why did you try to do
philosophy in the first place why did
you try to explain it
why didn't you stay within the realm of
math and just do your stupid equations
why did you have to come into physics
and try to give it a physical
interpretation which is bunk which is
nonsense
and then at the end say well after all
it's we don't understand it it's
philosophy anyways it's not part of our
discipline it's not part of science
if it's not then why the hell did you
try to give a physical interpretation
and give the semblance of knowledge
give the impression that you knew
something this is where the problem is
okay what is it under the rope model
here's a this is
our version okay um
first we go with the variables and
they're similar but a little different
because we have interconnectivity
remember
uh the rope model says that all atoms in
the universe are
interconnected and they're connected by
uh
pair of twined dna like ropes okay so we
have two threads intertwined
it torques and it stimulates both atoms
simultaneously
light travels both ways so to speak in
other words the torsion
happens or impacts the atoms at the two
ends
at the same time okay that's why i see
you you see me
the ropes are pumping in both directions
simultaneously
okay the rope ends in an atom that's the
connectivity
or it can run through the atom
remember what is our atom or atom is a
balloon
and we're saying it runs through the
atom okay that's another possibility
or it can run between two atoms okay
extent extend
between two atoms okay uh motion
again we have a solid fluid and gaseous
you know depending
on how fluid something is okay frequency
now we can talk about link length
not wavelength because we don't know
what a wave is these people are still
trying to figure that out they're in
their dark basement trying to brainstorm
find out what this
wavy thingy is and we've already told
them here
we do have a physical object it's a a
rope
looks more or less like this this is
what a rope looks like
okay two threads twined around
like no questions asked hopefully yeah
very straightforward
and uh we're talking about link length
the length of a link okay there's a
link okay and um
so if it's within the visible range okay
between
uh infrared and ultraviolet which is a
question of how long the link
is okay or if it's outside
either below infrared above
ultraviolet those are the constraints
and then density again how many
molecules
per centimeter cube okay
and there is an experiment you should do
at home
you know let me get this out of here
and it looks more or less like this you
take a laser
pointer okay i'm going to shine it at my
hope you can see it there okay
black shirt okay and if if you put a
cardboard in front you can see that
i'm making the uh i can't do both at the
same time
okay there it is
see it disappears when i put the uh
cardboard in front of it look how thin
it is
very thin okay okay you can see it
very thin piece of cardboard
and the laser doesn't go through it but
the laser you just saw went through
water through air
a lot more atoms here in fact don't take
my word for it go to the nearest
pool swimming pool near your home
you can see to the bottom of i don't
know 10 feet of water you can see your
reflection down at the bottom
that means light went from you all the
way to the bottom
through all those same atoms all the way
to your eye again that's why you can see
yourself
reflected down there unless you believe
uh you know that you're reflected from
the top
but you know you could see things at the
bottom of the pool
so you can see through that whole layer
of water
and certainly that whole layer of water
has a little more
thickness meaning a lot more
material a lot of more atoms a lot more
molecules
than this piece of cardboard so
it's not a question of how much matter
there is it's primarily a
transmission in the case of quantum
mechanics if they could explain what is
uh going through there what corpuscle or
whatever what particle what thing
is going through there in the case of
the rope all we have is
one atom connected to another atom which
is connected to another atom
by a dna like rope
entity okay and it looks more or less
like this
okay here you see it okay so we have
a light going to the water going right
through air why because it's connected
to all these atoms
okay and of course i've only shown two
ropes here
and you have to think of this also not
as something moving as you see there
because that changes from second to
second okay
what we have is ropes attached to ropes
and what is being not transmitted but
relayed
are the signals from one atom to another
okay that's why you know these
what quantum says essentially is correct
it's a question of transmission it's not
that
light goes through all these atoms it's
that it's connected to the atom and the
atom
re-transmits the signal by relaying it
it receives this uh this vibration
and it retransmits it to another atom
which retransmits it to another atom
it's a relay race okay and again those
atoms
are connected to each other and so they
receive the same stimulus all the way
down the line
so it's another uh mechanism that we're
proposing a physical mechanism that you
can
sink your teeth into and that's that
it's not transmitted because the way
they explain it in quantum mechanics is
light hits an atom strikes it right
because it throws this little
photon ball which is not a ball that
hits the atom
really hits the electron which is not a
ball either
it's a nothing but somehow it hits it
very good aim
and by doing so that electron
is able to re-transmit that
photon to another atom which receives
whose electron receives and re-transmits
it and so on down the line
so it's a relay race but in quantum it's
not a relay race
because it's uh it's a hitting race okay
one hits the other one and
it's a chain reaction in a sense under
the rope model it's a relay race because
one atom sends the signal to another the
torsion signal
to another which retransmits that same
torsion signal to another why because
that atom is pumping it's pumping
remember it's a balloon
and that balloon is expanding and
contracting quantum jump
and that's what's being stimulated that
re
transmits relays
that same signal to the atom behind it
is on the line
so yeah it's primarily a um a mechanism
of relay that's what it is under the
rope model
okay let's look at our conclusions today
okay here we have it
um air water and glass are transparent
and i have to state that because there
are people who
when they're asked that question
especially if you go to quora
they go on a tangent say well you know
if you pour ink inside the water
and they go off on all these tangents
let's bring rational people in let's
let's see if we can address the question
and the question is are air water and
glass transparent the answer is
yes period
stop okay yes they are transparent okay
transparency is not a function of
quantity of substance
how thick something is it's a question
of whether
it can re light can be retransmitted
that atom has the ability to retransmit
remember you can have water for example
and it's completely clear you can see
right through it
you put some red ink in there you know
and suddenly it gets cloudy and
it doesn't you can't see through that
red ink for some reason
so it's the red ink the stuff that you
put in there that somehow
is preventing the transmission of that
light now it reflects that
light it absorbs and only allows the
dispersion of this red light which
is being reflected back to your eyes
okay
and um under the rope model uh
re-transmission
is relay okay it's a relay type of race
okay i just explained that quantum
mechanics has no justification for the
transverse wave
quantum mechanics proposes that a
particle is a function or
an equation therefore both quantum
mechanics proposals
are irrational they cannot explain
a physical mechanism they cannot provide
a physical
interpretation to transparency
okay and with that
we close that subject okay so you're
welcome to
ask questions for next week meanwhile
let's address the questions that people
ask
since last time okay one fellow says
says uh mass mass
mass is how much matter an object
contains
no people learn that in high school they
learn it by rote
and people should start parenting what
they don't understand
okay and mass is a constant for a body
that doesn't change with location
absolutely not okay mass changes
together with weight with location
okay the kilogram is a unit of mass
and it's also a unit of weight
say bill what are you talking about okay
so we take lay kilo
you know the the old standard because
now they have a new standard for
uh weight for i'm sorry for the kilogram
and uh did we count how many atoms
are in that kilogram in that standard
now the way we determined
uh the kilogram is by weighing it we say
this is one kilogram
of mass and one kilogram of weight
you say ah bill i'm going to fool you
i'm going to take it to the moon
and you're going to see that the weight
changes but the mass
remains the same and
how do you know the mass remained the
same if you didn't count atoms [ __ ]
which is what this guy is saying saying
the quantity of matter
quantity of matter i hope you counted
every atom in there is that what you did
or did you weigh it see
you say the weight change but mass did
not but it turns out mass
weight and it changed as well together
with a mass with the weight because
the way you determine massive by wayne
no mathematicians on planet earth ever
was able to separate to isolate mass
from weight they give you this lip
service saying well mass is the quantity
of matter
and it turns out that's not true either
okay
and here you have uh don't take my word
for it
let's get some big shots here okay we
have here uh mr john wheeler
famous so-called mathematical physicist
and mr edwin taylor another one
and says nature they wrote this in
space-time physics
nature does not offer us any concept as
the amount of matter history has struck
down
every proposal to define such a term
even if we could count number of atoms
or by any other counting
method try to evaluate amount of matter
that number would not equal mass
and it should have uh become quite
evident you know because if
to those who are into mathematical
physics
okay you go to the um
physics fact uh frequency asked
questions
um you'll find that uh
they try to explain relativistic mass
what the hell is relativistic mass well
it has to do with speed
has to do not with quantity of matter
because they're not saying that
as you accelerate something it picks up
more matter more atoms more molecules
into that substance so if i were to
accelerate
i don't know this pen right what they're
saying if you accelerate close to the
speed of light its mass
increases special relativity
okay that's what they say okay so it's
mass increases why did it increase
what are we saying did more atoms
accumulate and the pen accumulated more
atoms more
molecules is that what happen or is a
question of
speed pressure how far or how close it
is to something
gravity see because if mass
increases with speed then mass is weight
what they've been talking about is
weight and if they say that
relativistic mass is a
special type of mass yeah it's weight
that's all they said
and again that means mass and weight
have no difference between
and here just in case icing on the cake
we have how they measure
some things and this is just from
you can just google this it says what
way
what objects weigh one kilogram
i thought kilogram was a measure of mass
and here they say way okay and so they
go through all these uh examples of what
weighs one kilogram and they say
all weigh approximately one kilogram
then they give some other examples there
okay so uh what is mass well it's uh
measured in kilograms what is weight
well for some reason it's also measured
in kilograms
so i guess uh mass and weight are the
same thing after all right
okay another issue fellow brings up says
that same file i think yeah mass a
coherent defines it
mass a coherent typically large body
absolutely not mass is not a body of
matter
with no definite shape no
concepts don't have shape and mass is a
mathematical concept
so no it doesn't have shape sorry to
inform you
and then you look up the definitions in
encyclopedias and wikipedia and hyper
physics and so on
and what do you find for mass well it's
a measure of something it's a resistance
it's a property it's a measure of
property measure all concepts
so mass is not a thing you can't say a
mass did did a mass did that
it's not a body it's not a shape okay so
you got to learn the basics of before
you get into physics
okay should take a course in physics
so that you learn the basics at least
you know
okay uh file says something about weight
okay it says weight is the force exerted
on mass by gravity
and so is mass weight is the amount of
matter that something is made of
which you said is mass
weight is not a constant it changes from
place to place
and so does mass because we never count
atoms when we take the
leg hello to the moon we weigh it and
uh that's how we determine its mass so
again we're going around in circles
we're going around in circles because
they never defined
a mass in such a way that they could
isolate it from weight
we determine mass by weighing we don't
count atoms
that's why mr wheeler and mr
taylor there said that mass is not the
amount of
matter and then the black hole you
heard my argument on that when you have
a circular argument
black hole crushes all matter out of
existence
it turns out black holes have mass but
no matter
so mass cannot be the quantity of matter
right and uh so we're back to square one
because you know again
crush is out of existence uh black hole
has mass
but it has no matter circular argument
mathematics has that constantly you know
that's because
in great measure because they never
define these terms
okay what does matter this foul talks
about matter
okay let's see what this is matter
physical substance
that's how he defined it well we got a
problem because the word physical and
the word substance our synonym
with the word matter what is physical
that which is material
matter okay substance physical matter or
material
a species of matter material what is
that it's a substance or substance of
which i think is made up
so uh we don't have a definition because
other all they use is synonyms okay so
no that's not what matter is in science
physics we define matter as the
uh set i guess you could say
of objects that exist instead of
objects that exist we call that matter
it could be a subset and we see
if that's what we're going to use for
your presentation your
talk and you say well this is a
small part we're going to call this
matter it's all the objects there that
exist
okay so that's what it is only objects
that exist
form the word matter okay another
issue a fellow raises he says magnets
magnets do not attract each other okay
they both move towards a null point in
counter space ooh
counter space you know that's when uh uh
all the space you need on the counter
for your beer okay that's called counter
space okay
there is no such thing as magnetic
attraction okay
if you don't understand ether you don't
understand reality
yeah we do understand ether at least in
this side here's the ether
case just so you know what the ether is
for everybody there okay
that's that's the ether it's a bunch of
particles that
uh supposedly are within space
some people equate the particles with
space and say that space
and those particles are the same thing
but essentially
the ether is the vibration of those
particles
and that's what they say light is or
that's what they thought it was in the
19th century
that you know the light is simply the
vibration of the ether meaning a bunch
of particles okay
and so that's the ether we know what the
ether is now the question is is there
such a thing as ether
and the answer is absolutely not we have
no use for the word ether because ether
is a
term of religion not of science not a
physics okay
we have no use for ether either
essentially amounts to
meteorology you know what something is
made out of
and they're saying that the wave is made
out of all these particles
and okay we we can accept that but the
question is you cannot explain a single
phenomenon with that
because you would have to explain why
the particle goes up and down among
other things you know i mean if it's
going to wave
what how is it waving well the particle
has to go up and then has to go down
and the question is what is pulling the
up particle or pushing the particle up
what is pushing or pulling the
particle down are all these particles
tied to each other
by some little thread or something
you know so you got to explain all that
stuff before you can use the word wave
in terms of the ether okay
another issue fellow says
how do you explain ropes in making
matter from light which we have recently
achieved
oh very simple under the rope model is
straightforward
turns out the rope is what makes which
makes light right which is that thing
there also makes the atom
so straightforward there you have matter
being made out of the same threads that
make up the rope
we're done okay very straightforward
good so yeah the rope turns into
light which turns into atoms which turns
into light which turns into atom
at infinitum and another fellow asks or
brings up the issue of plasma he says
plasma
physics is a mystery to the standard
model cosmologist
okay they recognize of course that
plasma is the what
fourth state of matter okay there's no
physical object called the fourth state
of matter that i know of okay but maybe
you can bring it to the conference room
and say this is the fourth state of
matter here it is this is what it looks
like
but the puzzle piece doesn't fit their
model other
pieces and so it is ignored indeed it
requires the understanding that all
matter is composed of
elements created by the dielectric force
magnetism
and which field is the ether of
magnetism dielectric force
the universe in which demurge also
creates gravity
as a bright product yeah there's no such
thing as plasma
no physical object uh plasma
is i mean if if you define it as the
fourth state of matter for sure there's
no
physical standalone object called force
state of matter okay so
and if you can define the word it cannot
be an object
objects we point to okay and name them
plasma is ionized gas ionized atoms
that's what plasma is defined as and if
it's defined it's a concept
it's not a physical object why because
ionized means something is happening
a kangaroo that is jumping is not an
object
kangaroo is an object if the kangaroo is
jumping a jumping kangaroo does not
qualify
as an object it's a movie
objects are statues they don't move you
point to them and say kangaroo
if it jumps now you got a movie now you
got a concept a dynamic concept
and plasma is a dynamic concept it's not
a physical object there's no such
physical object standalone called
plasma okay plasma plasma is not a thing
plasma is a thing in motion and there
you see
an example okay so you can't use the
word plasma as a physical object
in science in physics okay not everybody
understands that especially the
people from the electric universe they
have a hard time understanding that
their
uh beautiful hypothesis their plasma
is not a physical object oh man that
drives them up the walls
okay another foul says says
didn't nasa state a couple years ago
that our atmosphere expands beyond the
moon
and that the space between the earth and
the moon isn't actually space
because it's full of hydrogen uh
no the the vacuum level
between the earth and the moon is 10 to
the minus 11 torr it's been measured a
couple times at least
okay and so there's very little matter
in per cubic centimeter okay that's one
issue
the other one is that you're probably
confusing it with
the fact that quantum mechanics says
that space is made out of particles
you know you have a positive particle
and a negative particle they get
together and they form a new
particle and then that no particle can
separate between positive and negative
particles that's what
quantum mechanics says maybe that's
where you got the idea that it's full of
hydrogen
now it's not full of hydrogen it's full
of uh
positrons and electrons that that's
essentially their uh
their argument okay so just keep that in
mind
okay um paul says
says aha this is the wolinski guy okay
it says i find jeffrey wilinski's
stellar metamorphosis is the most
convincing
yeah it's just no problem there except
that
jeff did not come up with that okay i've
got a video on that
okay you can look it up the earth is uh
older than the sun
that's the name of the video you can
look it up but if you look at the video
i gave credit to jeff wolinski
because i thought originally that it was
his
uh further uh research showed that it's
mr
alexander o'paran he came up with it in
1924
a little earlier before mr wolinski was
born
okay in the book called the origin of
life on earth
he says the following let me
get this higher it says there was a time
when the earth too
was passing through the same stage of
development as the sun
namely that of being a yellow star
later as it gradually radiated its
heat outwards into the cold
interplanetary space
it became cooler and cooler it turned
from a
yellow star into a red one its light
became dimmer and dimmer and finally
went out all together
the earth became a dark planet
mr o'parent says that the earth
was a star okay and i put a video out
there
i gave credit to mr wolinski erroneously
and i do clarify that in the description
so you got to read the description of
that video to find out
who really came up with this theory it's
mr o'parent mr wilinski did not
add a single grain of sand
to that idea okay so he should not get
any credit for that
and i'm really sorry that he misled me i
thought it was a good idea
and the reason i think uh
it's a good idea for two reasons really
one is that it explains the
why the earth is round okay it sits
around because
the earth was a star and if you look at
the star
uh any star it's um differentiated
like the earth is in other words get the
heavier elements
in the center and as you go outwards you
get the lighter elements until you get
to the
completely to the skin of the planet
which is what
a gas enclosure oxygen nitrogen and so
on
gases so the earth is structured like a
star
and it turns out that all roundish
spherical celestial objects
were stars if they're dead i mean if
they're like
mercury or rocky planets or rocky moons
or
rocky asteroids but when you get to
jupiter and some of these uh
saturn uranus all these are big gaseous
planets they are stars that never
ignited that's a little different
process
but the earth was a star at one point in
time
and what's left this is the cinder of
that star and that's what became the
earth
and why is the earth older than the sun
because the earth was already there when
the sun
finally ignited and just captured the
earth in its orbit
so the earth was already there
thousands millions of years before the
sun ever came to be
the sun could have formed i have no
problem with that with the nebular
hypothesis for those who know
what i'm talking about and capture the
earth
which was a little stone or what was
left of
a uh an ancient very ancient
star and that's what mr o'brien came up
with
okay uh two more things here two more
questions one
file says get this up here
according to the wikipedia at the moon's
surface the beam
laser is about 6.5 kilometers uh
four miles wide he's talking about the
retro reflector the um
lunar ranging experiment okay that i
covered the other day so even if the
moon
uh relative speed is around one
kilometer
yeah per second is it should be easy to
hit the
retro reflectors yeah i'm not saying
it's not
okay so let's get it right they shine
the laser very powerful laser at the
retro reflector which they more or less
know where it's at it's close to a
crater so they point the
laser somewhere near that
crater and they know they're going to
hit the retro reflector even though they
cannot see it
but they know that if they receive a
signal back they know they hit that
retro reflector and that's what the
detector on earth captures puts it into
a computer and then they see a peak and
they say okay we hit the reflector
what do they do that for for a lunar
arranging what is lunar arranging
they're trying to figure out how far the
moon is and whether it's going farther
away or closer to the earth that's why
what the experiment is for but it's a
good test
for light because
you see there what's happening you know
if the earth shoots
these photons these discrete photons
it has to go first in a curve because it
has to go through warp space
downwards so if the earth is weighing
the uh space time downwards so that the
moon can move around it
like a roulette well then the photons
are
balls are sliding through which are not
balls by the way
but all these photon balls these are
little particles
they have to roll down the same warp
space
to reach the moon is that what they do
they shoot them
so perfectly that they know that light
is going to curve through
warp space no what they do they shoot it
directly at the
crater and then they're going to find a
retro reflector more or less
what is it a 6.5 kilometer radius
or diameter okay so uh
they know they're going to hit it why
because light is not a bunch of
particles and there's no such thing as
space time that's why
because if there was a thing such a
space down there and
photons were little balls they would
roll down that
uh you know warp space
and we would never get a single photon
back that's not what they do
they point it directly at the retro
reflector that's how that works
okay and remember you have to factor in
there that
the earth is moving at 30 kilometers per
second
around the sun and the moon is rolling
one kilometer per second
around the earth so it's moving you know
when one guy moves the other guy's
moving around
so the moon is moving faster than the
earth in that sense okay
so not only are they moving but then you
have warped space you have these little
photon balls rolling down
warp space how do they do it now they
point it directly at the retro reflector
at the crater and they
get a signal back okay last one here
fell says what's the rope made of well
that's the easiest question i got today
the rope is made of threads see how easy
it was
you have two twine threads you want to
call them strings
wires coaxials whatever you want to call
it no problem i call them threads
so it's made out of two threads twine
threads see how easy it was
that's what the electromagnetic rope is
made out of
okay with that i will see you on
wednesday
and we'll continue battering
the mechanics quantum mechanics
the most irrational theory you can